hey what's up guys my name is a chero
welcome to uh episode one of a new
series I'm going to call this chero
craft officially now and uh what we're
doing here is part from killing each
other we're on a map here called um The
Walls 2 two two yeah this is this is the
second version and uh it's much improved
from the first one and I'm I'm just damn
excited to play this I haven't played
this yet uh so we've got a bunch of
people here we've got um got a few of my
friends so like Soper uh Flappy I not
even going pronouncing your name um the
D and our Nightfall and then I've also
got a few fans in here like uh hold
still um in I can't pronounce your name
inil in
in know there we go um this this Joker
here uh van stop crouching van s um and
uh Wade and um is that everyone no I
think there's one more pyromancer pyro
pyromancer where is he chasing you
behind you I see him I see him all right
um so that's that's the people in here
uh do any do any of you have like
YouTube channels that I can link in the
description y all right uh do you want
to go from the top someone come in front
of me and just announce your your
Shameless self-promotion I can't
remember mine yeah you don't have that
SAU I do like my YouTube channel I don't
mean I don't mean a Channel with like
zero subscribers and zero videos I think
I've got two so just you
know yeah okay so let's get
it um actually put put put your channel
put your channel just type it into the
so just hit T and type in your channel
into the uh like you youtube.com/
whatever your channel name
is I love how everyone's like
still and I'll um I'll link all God The
Cho you real someone actually took the
Cho which I'm kind of upset about yeah
what's your actual one well like the one
that this is going on to the Cho project
oh yeah that's right all right so Sly
Fox Hound yep Sky all right so anyway um
I'll I'll link them all into the
description okay so what's going to
happen now is the rules of this are
pretty simple basically there are two
teams sorry four teams of two and they
all get one of these quadrants and as
you can see I'm just flying over the uh
the quadrants now so they starting these
little pods here F go fly go fly away
they are they they they start in these
little pods here and what happens is
once the once I once I flip a switch and
actually start the game the uh the timer
starts and they have 20 minutes and it's
not actually 20 minutes it's like cuz 1
minute is 57.2 seconds um they have 20
minutes to basically just try and get
ready for a massive battle in their
quadr and what happens is after no it's
20 after well it says 20 on the signs so
it's 20 minutes no 15 on the signs it
says 20 um and uh so what's going to
happen is once once that 20 minutes is
up and that timer will actually count
down it's in minutes so once that gets
to zero these walls will all collapse
and you actually just kill each other
literally justy I mean I mean Wes SAU is
already killing not sure if everyone
knows this but there is the only diamond
in the game is right in the middle of
the map so the
tactic there are there's five there are
five six diamond blocks in the um in the
middle of the map and they're the only
diamond in the map and basically again
the the last team who is alive the
surviving team is just wins the wins the
game and gets it's
like have team names is it just no if
it's don't kill your own if if you're
like the only two people left and you're
on the same team don't kill each other
you like you both won no no no what I
mean is like what if your teammate gets
killed and then you've got a bad
teammate I bet s will be the first boy
um but yeah okay so that's pretty much
going to settle it so I'm going to give
everyone creative um mode now do not
okay one of the rules is uh you actually
can't destroy the Bedrock obviously but
you can D destroy the sand walls do not
okay do not destroy the sand walls to
separate these quadrants that is a rule
um and that's pretty much it so again
I'm just going to give you all let me
just get the Syntax for this all right
so creative mode to okay so I'm going to
do this one at a time just to make sure
that we're we do this legit so sauce
come with me we're taking this one this
quadrant right here oh this is the best
one you you put the diamonds in here
right oh wait
what all right come over here SS follow
me and park yourself in one of these
pods Park myself which pods where you
see the you see like the holes ground y
y I see um I see now okay so now I'm yep
deactivate my game mode okay there we go
try and get out of there just it is
possible cannot be done uh I'll sort
I'll sort Jamie out before he like
figures out a way to cheat or something
so I want to do
thata
don't know what talking
about I can't do
it and Flappy come with me both of you
Jamie and
Alex are you guys flying I can't see you
know how do you fly double double tap
space just space bar it's not working oh
I didn't I CU I didn't type out your
whole name I thought that would work but
apparently not okay um the
go hear a cow oh there's a cow right
next to my spawn Jamie can you fly as
well I can't do it J I'll you through
I'll hit you through ready okay do it do
it jump oh can you actually not fly no I
can't do
it oh my bad I'm using the wrong damn
syntax
I'm okay um Flappy to gong okay sir
you're good oh
cool and Jamie come with me so um Alex
just follow me both of you Jamie you're
like way behind mate spe I can't go up
oh hold space bar you Noob wow okay I'm
going to like run out of disc space by
the time we start this damn game I got
200 gigs fore so that should be good uh
okay into the pods choose any pod there
like I don't care which one you choose
what are pods oh there's little holes in
the ground oh okay I want the one on the
left double tap space bar to stop Flying
drop down and land in one of them and
just no I want the one I want this one
Alex it's like in
the okay now get yourself in that pod so
I can see that you're in it you you can
go on the same pod
wonderful okay next team with who
everyone shut up who's on a team with
who now I don't remember okay so you
being so van and Pyro yes okay so van
ZN fly
[Music]
away
maner all right both of you go into the
far left
quadrant okay I believe Mr Cho should we
be like a you should be
quiet shut down okay so there's uh two
little pods here well actually there's
three what I was actually going to say
should we go on our own Skype calls now
yeah no not yet oh you can if you want
actually yeah just get out of my call
Jamie before you ruin get out of my call
bye-bye
bye okay now that he's out of the call
one more um oh baby one
baby okay hang on what was your damn
name again um oh I can just here
actually hello van see hello okay sweet
you both in survival okay and the last
two Save The Best For Last
right yeah you might want to like s or
something oh my God this cow is annoying
for
me did you seriously just no not you God
we got home don't suicide if you're in
the Pod cuz then
you I'm already back don't worry don't
worry we're
good oh he's red too bad uh I'm a little
claustrophobic so could we get this okay
um okay
so Ina as I'm just going to call you
you're sweet and oh whoops I said it's a
survival my bad oh that does not
work okay
and Wade see Wade's got a really easy
name okay so you're in the far right
quadrant hang on what happened to to the
guy who like suicided who was in the Pod
that was me don't worry it's all fine
got my home set oh did you set home when
you went in the Pod oh such a boss I
didn't even think of
that all right so yeah just um SAU are
you kidding me it didn't
work did you set home all right so yeah
is the
best just descend just dude I love how
this intro is going to be like like 10
minutes I don't know it's going be
longer than the actual match yeah oh I
don't know is going to be a while
putting people in there n screw it I'll
just mode let everyone
suffer so get into the Pod skip to this
o to all right sweet yeah I might like
an annotation or
something all
right I'm just eating some fruit to get
myself you know in the mode gu oranges
mhm got it oranges apples bananas
everything I'll just cut it for myself
so I can um party right I'm putting
myself into the Pod oh I see oh wait I
should probably start the game first
yeah but that's unfair CH no no no your
home in the Pod so there's like 15
seconds left before it actually starts
after I hit the start button and take
yourself off creative please yeah
obviously mate well I don't know and in
fact you okay oh one more Pro tip here
you can actually hold control to sort of
I didn't know this so you guys probably
do but um you can hold control like zoom
in a lot what that's only if you have
opine oh really yeah okay I didn't
know awesome
Advantage yeah well no there's still
control in Mac it's not the control yeah
who cares it's still control okay uh so
I have to I actually have to set like
survival for myself to press the button
then jump back to creative and then fly
and then go back to survival just push
is everyone ready everyone in your pods
yep three two one oh actually hang
on split uplit up split up into your own
calls into whatever yeah get
strategizing yeah so just bye see you
all right sauce we're sweet let me okay
so what are we doing getting wood first
no we haven't started yet yeah I know
but like okay yeah so what's the plan of
attack what get yeah I know what you
meant okay uh when I push this button
which I just did yeah
um I'm flying all the way to you right
now so what's going to happen is the
first thing we're going to do is yeah
you just get wood just build like a
basic
stuff
um okay sweet who okay see we're up okay
awesome getting
[Music]
wood go on a different Tree to me yeah
obviously I'll go this one what am I
doing are we making a craft bench or
yeah my god you're kidding what look at
the kill look at the look at the
thing a they suffocated in walls the
hell
happened and that's the series see
everyone oh
[Music]
God I reckon the the Pistons oh but
they've already set home well but
they've set home so that's like cheating
if they die crap I didn't think of that
no but they don't spawn at their home
they spawn at the spawn and they go SL
home to go there oh yeah but that's
still
cheating probably shouldn't have put
um okay what am I doing am I making wood
okay we're just going to continue on
planks wooden planks am I making wooden
planks yeah just um I don't know yeah
okay we want a craft bench and we want
to we want to start mining stone like
ASAP okay I've got a crafting bench over
here awesome yeah yeah don't build
multiple crafting benches you built one
great I'm going to make a wooden
pick yeah we want to make some sticks
first
and
can you actually just make um pickaxes
for both of us so I don't waste wood
making a wooden pickaxe thanks oh what
you mean a cobble yeah Cobble yeah grab
grab like six Cobble blocks um okay I
don't want to waste time okay there's a
farm here and there's actually a chest
here I'm going to just explore that
there are chests scatter around there's
actually an end chest right underground
as well uh yes okay there's a redstone
repeaters toy Pistons what do they do oh
okay oh we can use that to like engineer
sick and twisted ways of killing people
exactly uh we got 16 string which means
that I can build bows right now okay um
I'm I'm going to build up some bows we
need to find some arrows as well um okay
so
bow one bow and here I got a pick for
you sweet thanks okay uh your bow is on
the ground cheers right what am I doing
I'm just going further seeing what else
I can mine yeah yeah startop mining dude
and um I'm going to come over here and
try and uh we need we need arrows so we
need okay I'm just going to get some of
this like whatever the hell this is we
probably want to find iron to get some
IR yeah we want to get iron like ASAP
and also what's iron good for us yeah we
want an we want yeah but we also want an
iron pick we want an iron pick to be
able to get that
diamond we don't really need coal do we
oh no we do oh [__] we do for smelting I
mean oh we also need food don't um I'll
I'll I'll deal cow we can go kill some
cows yeah yeah I'll I'll deal with food
you deal with mining okay
okay so I'm just mining down like yeah
do whatever dude just find us
mine can I'm in a ravine like underg oh
found some found some uh Cobble I mean
no got five wool I don't know what that
does though oh um I found a chest I mean
not a [__] chest a freaking yeah iron
that's what I mean Iron all
right it' suck if I fell and died it
would okay uh there's some
um sugar canane here what's sugarcan
good for a puff like oh I found a chest
under water dude you can make paper
bottle of
enchanting Golden Apple awkward potion
uh TNT two TNT dude 13 arrows and five
bones potion is used for like oh crap
crap crap crap i' like I was just
chilling in the water forgot about the
fact that I can only breathe for a
limited time but um I I made it out of
alive okay uh I'm going to I'm going to
find myself some Cobble okay I got some
more make make a furnace uh grab coal
while you're down there bro um I can't
see any coal I've got lots of iron but
no coal yeah you we need coal like I
mean we no we could we could use wood
technically wait can people teleport to
each other no like send requests oh I'm
under a Bedrock they shouldn't be able
to oh should be able to got a lot of
coal
sweet oh crap stuck in
here all right oh W this is a good IR
okay I'm on 14
iron all right all right all right um
let's
see okay that's that's fine I need um uh
furnace tell me when to come back up
sure dude as soon as oh so you found
coal yeah yeah I've got like 13 coal oh
that's brilliant um do you have iron uh
yep come up here with all your iron and
all your coal put it into that furnace
that's just like here and um get lost or
something um but I'll um I'll I'll go
down where you I'll take your place for
a second oh also hang on also you'll
find right next to the furnace uh two
staks uh grilled
them F us y okay I've lost my the way I
came down I I see your name tag
dude oh my God where the oh wow yeah
this is quite a I see you dude see me
I'm up I'm up look up yeah yep some more
iron in the wall wait I'm going up this
waterfall there are Vines as well oh
there's so much coal here oh wait is
that iron y I found more iron this is
like so dangerous cuz if you fall down
here you're like oh oh dude I almost
died I'm on three let's try to avoid
that I like just said if you fall
down um
[__] and my health like won't regenerate
either cuz I'm like on low food why
didn't you suicide before you came here
no I did I just I lost food like while I
was what while while I was
walking okay night Peter good my little
brothers went to bed sweet okay I'm
going back so okay so smel the iron
first or do the steaks first do the
steaks first man I need
food okay here we go
Stakes like them in
there um do you want me to make any more
Cobble found tons of um I I I could do H
do we need we don't need that much wood
do we no probably don't I've already got
got 41 planks so yeah yeah we'll be
right do you want me to get a sword and
go kill like some sheep or whatever
animal yeah yeah try and gather food
while I'm down here Mining and I just
found like a freaking prison okay good
so wait can we make cookies with cocoa
beans uh I think so what open the wood
or something if you're not sure what
chest do what end chests do I think it
just lets you like oh I found something
dude I found um I found another chest I
think ender chests just let you like um
if there's mult end chest like on the
map you can your stuff anywhere so it's
like a little torter okay do I want to
kill this sheep I found flint and steel
dude oh flint and steel that's good can
that be good for setting other people on
fire yeah a that's what it's used for I
also found a cobweb a bucket if I can
fill up with lava cobweb if you can like
if we canly we can trap people someone
oh that's useful got eight iron as well
what am I doing with all this iron sh am
I making a pick or a sword or both um
you're making I can make a pick and a
sword for but I suppose yeah yeah do
that I'm like super careful right now as
well cuz if I fall again I'm
dead
[Applause]
okay I've got a pick for you sweet just
waitting my sword okay I think I'm on my
way back now okay I've got one steak for
you
too oh no wait hang on where's the exit
it's up the fall a bit just dig up like
if you can't find it yeah I guess I'll
but this there's a gravel here I want to
like fall on me and kill me okay found
more more iron I think I might go for
that I've Got Dirt blocks or should I
just start making a mine somewhere
else um maybe right I've got a sword and
a don't don't forget that yeah we just
need like iron we want full iron armor
basically all of us like both of us
there's iron
cooking um okay I'll go back down into
the mine and you can see where I am to
come up yeah um okay I'm coming in the
way I'm I'm I'm mining some iron right
now as well I might just go to the
bottom um also there aren't any monsters
enabled obviously it's one of the rules
so um it's not like people it's not to
kill each other like Monsters won't be
able to they won't be like skeletons see
where I I'm just going to go down here
fell okay I'm at the yeah I'm at the
bottom right now do you want a steak
Yeah
I'm right here behind
you
thanks oh wait take a sword and a pig
thank
you wait okay I'm regenerating Health
that should
be yeah I am s okay umak Stakes do um
four yeah they're really good really
tasty best food item I believe yeah yeah
it is okay I've got 36 Cobblestone right
now I'm just going to start build like a
tire yeah yeah do that oh I found oh I
found a Bedrock first of all but I found
an actual like mine I
think and it goes all the way down okay
go back up and check on the iron because
there only six blocks left so yeah I'll
go
up I should just mine up or yeah I don't
have I I think I don't think I've got
enough like um like stuff to do
that I'll
just getting a lot of Cobblestone okay
I'm just getting I'm just going off up
okay I've pretty much got full health
again I'm
fine oh hang on ooh I found a little
passageway to like another um thing oh
there's tons of iron here dude I found
like 10 iron in like one vein oh more
than 10 holy crap and like there's like
a whole room full of iron dude we're
sweed on iron I think we'll have enough
for how much iron did you how much iron
did you bring up um I think there was
six left by the time I done the swords
and the pigs okay well I've got 18 on me
right now and I can see 13 on me right
now oh that's awesome dude how much do
we need for a full set of armor not sure
one thing I know is that a helmet gives
you two 2.5 Hearts helmet and Boots do
the same thing chest PL best yeah yeah
yeah helmets and Boots do the same thing
but uh but boots cost less one less iron
to make yeah yeah yeah so go oh so much
iron make a chest plate
first okay I've been digging this tunnel
and nothing has come up I'm like quite
the opposite dude I've got 23 iron on me
right now and I can still see like a lot
more but I don't I don't think I want to
go down there and get it just not
yet okay um okay I just did a big
circuit and I'm back at
the
sweet okay I'm going to try and um I'm
just going to go up right now right
looks like there's something up here I'm
going to go check this
out what happened to the guys like die I
think they probably just went I I I hear
a fire
dude if if well I haven't started
complaining so nothing nothing like
terribly bad would have happened
probably um do should we get water for
something water uh yeah if you got a
bucket do you have a bucket no I don't
I've got a bucket um you know what I'll
yeah we might want to get water to like
put out a fire in case someone else
starts it I I'm Reon like if we get set
on fire keep it Buck you
um if I see one on the way I'll pick it
up I don't I don't know how much time
we've got left though dude um okay are
you still in the mine yeah I'm I'm I'm
working my way up do you reckon there'
be chests on top of the trees oh there's
water oh crap I just flooded the place
um I'll grab that bucket I reckon you
might find a chest on top of the
tree okay I've got a bucket of
water okay surf annoying wow this is
just like a pool of
water oh there I can hear a fire dude
should I come should I go towards it I'm
kind of scared well it'll probably
someone be someone in the
other yeah I'm I'm working my way
towards oh wao what is it
[__] it's really bright okay I'm oh here
we go oh it's wow here we oh I found a
holy crap I found an I found a chest
with an enchantment table holy [__] dude
solid and a fire charge what's that I
don't know an eight string five Redstone
three TNT I've got a five total five
total TNT okay well with eight string oh
with eight string you can
make
a oh that people don't have permission
to place
TNT oh [__] how do I enable that no clue
I'm going to waste time if I figure out
how [__] um we could just no TNT or
something what am I going to ditch just
make every
op
ah damn it I shouldn't have installed
freaking like bucket and stuff I just
thought that it might be better for no
trading okay iron pickaxe flint and
steel jungle wood I'll get rid of jungle
sapling jungle
wood we don't I don't think think we'll
need any more
wood okay when the walls go up yeah
there's a fire right here that's what
are we going to are we going to hide put
it out uh from what
everyone else are we can just hide in
the mine and holding shift so they can't
see our name
tag oh really the shift hide them at
name tag yeah I didn't know that cool um
dude I found an enchantment table so
like I'm going to just but I've got like
no
levels okay I'll put it down um where's
that iron sword dude I can hear someone
else digging that's me below you I'm
like coming out now I was scared that
was yeah yeah dude come here
um I've got bottle of enchanting hello
hang on let me
just damn okay so
where so you should have like lots of XP
or whatever now no I've got like half of
one level your mic's gone really weird
really y it's good now nope what
happened to it no clue I'm going to
check the time okay I'm up here I should
be fine whack in some more okay got I'm
putting 43 iron
in I need to make myself like level two
I'm going to make myself a new pick
I've also got a splash uh splash potion
of poison so that poisons them if it
hits them um I'm going to enchant
this I'm going to go look in trees and
see cuz I'm I reckon there would be a
chest in the tree somewhere H did you
get did you find a way out um yeah you
if you follow go one of the doors then
like I found some Netherrack as well I
don't know what that's yeah it goes out
into the nether is good because that
keeps burning never stops oh really yeah
cool all right um I'm on my way out soon
as I find a way
out oh hang on I think I see a way out
just if you went into the next yeah I
see it I see it I see it
wait oh should we make a a hoe and some
bread
um yeah probably I mean I don't know
dude what's the what what do the time is
what are we on um 4 minutes what holy
crap holy crap that went fast oh found a
chest in a tree oh got 16 arrows some
rotten flesh some bones and some um I'm
not even going to reply to Jamie check
the clock cu the cor yeah um melon what
dude seeds what can we do with seeds
cocoa beans um cookies I don't know I
don't know the crafting recipe for
cookies
though don't want rotten
flashh redstone lamp actually good
what's a redstone lamp
I found a chest with nothing in it dude
we need um we need we need to
immediately like make armor and weapons
and stuff okay well there's there's
stuff
cooking like a fair bit we got 10 so I'm
on 13 right now oh I'm going to add dude
we got 55 Al together that's that's
should be enough right I've got a golden
apple as well dude so I don't know okay
I've made myself a chest plate and some
booties I'll give you Bo booties you can
have the booties
here oh I got it though thanks
bro okay I've
got um we going to enchant anything like
I Reon enchant the
swords
um no I reckon yeah yeah yeah same
actually hang on where where did I come
from just then when when I um when I
when I resurfaced oh that was the that
was the water thing wasn't it yeah okay
I'm just going to go start digging
randomly over here cuz I'm going to go
enchant my sword right
now cuz the walls are like about to
open oh [__] this is scary do I want a
level two enchantment do I want to risk
it with that or should I just go level
one enchantment you got to risk it for
the biscuit okay sharpness one okay
that's good that's just more
damage good
awesome got some more
iron
okay um um do you have any Arrows by the
way because I've got 16 I've got 18 I've
got 13 sorry okay I've got 18 string
though so much
string all right uh let's see how do you
make a chest plate I of like missing
one some guy's like privately talking to
me I I made a chest plate
dude okay well I've already got one so
how are we doing with coal by the way
what's um oh sh I've got 36 in my
inventory there's eight left I think is
that eight or three eight we got eight
left so that's
fine I've still got like one more um no
I don't I'm out of food basically like I
mean I've got my food bar but I don't
have actually like I don't have I've got
rotten flesh I've got three rotten
flesh we should have probably made food
dude cuz it's going to like kill us if
we don't
okay let's see the timer says 1
minute oh [__] walls are about to fall
down I'm going to come back up because
I've got some more iron yeah I honestly
think we need to oh trip wire hook I
don't know see I don't know how this
stuff works in Minecraft yeah neither do
I so I'm like how am I supposed to I'm
going to do I'm going to do my research
for like the next episode of
this cuz I got no clue at the moment no
clue
zero my hide
yeah the walls
falling oh crap is
it I don't know dude let's just get onto
a tree yeah it it is the wall is falling
and I'm lagging I
can yeah I'm lagging as well it doesn't
matter just wait it out I guess dude I
need food like I'm I mean my food bar is
like I'm missing come on freaking pick
up the stupid iron you piece of crap is
there any more um there we go is there
any more um uh freaking livestock
around can't actually select the
workbench oh crap it's like crashing so
much sand dude like okay are we going to
make a rapid dash for the uh Diamond to
kill people yeah go to the diamond right
now follow me wait I'm just I make
myself some armor hurry up oh yeah so
should I
do we kind of missed the rapid Dash
there didn't we
y probably should just like started
waiting at the wall
we should have made two
furnaces oh well who cares I've got
sufficient armor anyway okay get a
sword let's go make rapid Dash oh I see
one
person should we get
him I missed like all my shots I I hit
him once you see him
yeah nothing in that
chest yeah it's cuz you already took
everything at me it was me I think
are they both empty y crap what kind of
light I'm going to Ste this guy's
enchanting
table there's no point I think oh she
died um I'm I'm going into the follow me
into the mine dude it's that mine maybe
they're still down
here crap holy crap
dude there's tons of iron dude that they
left behind well it's not like we're
going to be able to use much of it no
probably not oh a chest um dude what's
your health I mean
hunger yeah I'm like half dude okay did
you want a bit of rotten flesh I've got
a golden apple yeah thanks I've got a
golden apple as well so that that
restores like 10 doesn't it I think so
yeah so I'm I'm pretty much good for for
the time being
okay okay should we go down oh I don't
know man I reckon dude what about the
diamond oh okay we we'll go back up then
we toally neglected that didn't
we I think I was no we're not this way
well remember some people have already
um died yeah one person I stuck oh no oh
crap I almost died again I didn't know
that water water hurts apparently water
does hurt well if it's one block deep
then it hurts yeah I'm going to have to
eat that Golden Apple
Man okay where the freak is the exit
dude the golden apple restored like two
bars
hey where the freak is this exit
regeneration for a while do you know
where the exit is
no what I want to know though is The
High Ground okay so he's just camping in
a
tree pretty much I've got Fire charges
whatever the hell that does CL yeah
exactly where the hell how do we get
stuck okay oh it's up there I see dude I
need food as well I'm on like half
Health oh that almost crushed me join
the
club okay you should I brave it should I
go out and try and survive uh CRA we
just left all that iron burning in our
chest people just going to go steal that
oh crap we're smart oh we
are I'm just going to steal like the
coal yeah totally coal for IR any
[Applause]
day
come on I got to get to oh someone's
getting the diamond really stop them I
am I'm out of freaking hunger so I can't
run oh no yeah I'm pretty much the same
dude I've only got half Health dude I'm
going to die like
instantly my God I cannot hit with
arrows for crap okay I'm dude do a 360
no scope it'll be fine yeah they've got
the diamond [__] all of it
I don't know bro but
probably can't you stop them no that's
like freaking on a huge Tower I'm trying
to freaking shoot him with arrows
there's two of
them oh I'm I'm out into the real world
now they're coming at me are they yeah
dude get up here now I'm I'm bring the
okay I'm bringing the fight to you
they're here they're here he's got an
enchanted
sword yeah I'm dead I'm
dead
crap well that was fun that was episode
one
yeah
sup
okay I'm going to give you guys creative
mode
yeah oh that's
good
okay so what is it game
mode uh C okay so
Sofer okay and her name
is Ina something oh here we
go gu this one no player not
found okay
um
look check out Diamond
okay they got like full enchantment
going yeah okay we're going to spectator
mode yeah they got whoever that was they
got all the
diamond check these
chests see if there's anything left no
there anything here they probably like
did their homework about this kind of
game
probably can't see anyone can't see
anyone
either
they like freaking had enchantments and
crap going on so yeah here we go
someone's building a tree in the house I
mean a house in the tree a tree in the
house got Wade making a house in the
tree there's a lot of water on the
ground
here I know oh here he is yeah don't
like go near him so it's completely
obvious even though that is fairly
it's hard not to look there's another
one over on this
tree so who's like still it's only us
three that died right our team got
eliminated the first that's pathetic
it's cuz you brought them like to
me yeah yeah and I had no
Health where is
everyone probably
Underground
proba what we should have
done yeah
probably let's
um does fire oh Fire won't spread in
this
either why it because of oh [__] I just
destroyed a block because of bucket or
whatever it is yeah I'm I'm not using
bucket for the next episode I don't know
why I put it on I just copied and pasted
my old my my normal server probably a
problem
um so for the next
episode the winning team should like
stay on for the next episode yeah yeah
of course like you and me always there
yeah we'll um be dying first we'll stay
for the first season yeah
but like a finals finals thing yeah
exactly except we appear every time we
cannot get knocked
out and then we can add like
crazy
stuff like you know thing like after a
few minutes like look at wait he's just
freaking chilly he's parked himself like
on the highest possible point that the
girls yeah yeah he was he was I think
actually let me just check this maybe
should she come back in this calling
she's well she's probably she might be
oh crap might positions and stuff yeah
no I can't I can't yeah [__] um no but
apparently Wade killed her so what what
no no she fell to her death
okay okay I'll um pop her back
in oh
oh jeez van zeben going to
town double kill w someone just started
missing yeah dud he just killed oh wow
eliminated the whole team yeah just team
down oh there you go yud I didn't say
anything promise you no it's all right
it's all
right dude um yeah no some guy just
wiped out like Jamie and Alex's team
like instantly Who the hell's left it's
just it's Wade so in his team and who
else hang on um there's the two that
killed us just and he is dead so and
paner oh man this is epic so where give
creative is that guy Jamie did he yeah
we were lagging out both of was like
lagging out and then the like stopped I
got like a huge leg Spike and then it
looked like I was falling down and he
suddenly shot me and I fell down he was
like
no well I mean he's still alive so your
team could potentially win I know we
both were like panicking so bad although
although he is kind of just sitting on a
freaking tree yeah he's just
camping God what is he doing well like
how are they with his little to run out
of I don't know how many arrows he has I
wish I could say his inventory I don't I
think he only had like 20 or something
oh yeah he didn't have did he
just did he just he probably once I
escaped the hell did Jamie
do I don't trust I don't trust giving
creative mode to Jamie honestly just
going to put that out there do does
anyone know what fire charges do fire
charges yeah what fire charges do oh
here they go this is going to be this is
interesting turn get this on camera I'm
coming I'm coming they're coming oh
they're R in the
chests wait are there two of them yeah
two of them and a sheep is climbing a
tree yeah I see that see it oh that's
amazing oh no so hang on so who so
that's the last team down there there
Wade who's the last
man oh did you see that Arrow holy crap
oh he's going to die oh that's epic dude
that he just oh wow that's got flame on
the Arrow yeah holy crap oh this is
amazing I'm getting the best oh he's on
fire oh he's gone he's gone oh GG
they're on the same team right yeah okay
sorry yeah they're on the same
team okay I guess I'll get them back for
the uh for the next episode since they
um they're should do next episode or
like just a final Series where like
after five round no four rounds or maybe
three rounds we just doing it yeah well
I guess we'll keep doing it but um yeah
I don't know I don't know we might get
um some of these people back I don't
know do like I don't know I didn't I
didn't feel that this episode was really
fair cuz like TNT placement was off
um
fire next episode I'm just going to set
the whole thing on fire yeah we were
talking about the we were like we should
burn the whole forest and also what what
happened at the start where um and also
people like CH by teleporting to each
other we got certificated yeah how did
that happen and how did you resp idea
just the slash back thing and we just
like fall fall into the
thingy all right well um might be cool
just like you and me and we like suit
ourselves up in diamond stuff and then
it's six people versus us oh that could
be interesting it reminds me of I'm like
infected in like Modern Warfare 3 where
you just like got guns and you're
against people with
knives could be cool yeah I'm
here um all
right give creative to
Wade let's see
Wade okay so let me see so who who won
that that was that was van zeben and
pyromancer I think break
everything so van Z been P let this down
into like not he not Jamie says that
he's still alive Jamie is not still
alive lava oh no I can't play Lava es
the Glass Prison this guy got lucky with
the
enchantment okay so it was pyroman of
four
definitely pyran of 4 and Van Zen okay I
guess I'll be back for the next episode
um but everyone else I I'll definitely
get you back at a later date because I
don't think this was very fair but um
yeah no thanks everyone for for coming
out and playing um that was that was a
lot of fun um I really like this um this
game mode like this this map I think I
might um oh I'll definitely um I'll
definitely um you know continue doing
this um and uh yeah again I'll just I'll
go through the video and link your
YouTube channels in the description and
Y
yeah
Jamie yeah what's up Jamie we escaped
Glass Prison dude yeah and where are you
like it's not over we're still in in
this me and Alex have both escaped Glass
Prison and where are you didn't Alex
leave just because everyone else was too
terrible to escape Glass Prison H let me
just teleport to you real quick and see
what the hell are you doing destroying
like my server okay holy crap dude there
was an emerald here the other gent you
kill me I'll escape again boy oh how did
you
what I got out okay I'm not even going
to like bother dealing with that um okay
so did I just get a message
sent me a message and escaped again I'm
out I'm out son I broke the from a
different server because you you're
probably doing SL
back yep yeah exactly yeah everyone's
like cheating okay guys I'll get you
back for later episode I promise and um
yeah thanks for thanks for hanging out
and I'll uh I'll see you guys I'll see
all of you viewers in the uh in the next
episode later
[Music]
guys